[Music]
all right I'm beginning to feel better
after the drama I've got some music on
musics good I had a request for
balancing clockwise counter clockwise
moves like balancing say the fountain so
that you can do it both ways
equally and I've got a few thoughts on
that usually the way I started out take
a simple move like say shoulder real and
just loop it back and forth and find
whatever the move is find the smallest
loop possible if I do this I'm going
counterclockwise clockwise
counterclockwise clockwise and if I do
it for a while they will inherently
balance out and to make things
interesting you can play with things
like how high can you reach how do you
know can you reach all that kind of
stuff and you have music on you do it
with the beat
one two three I don't know if you hear
the music three four one two three four
one two that always makes it more
interesting for me to play with the
rhythm so that's one way another way
would be this if I'm going backwards
if I turn my back to you I can pass them
counterclockwise around my body if I
turn my front to you I passed some
clockwise around my body so if I just
turn back and forth again I just cycle
between them and one will start teaching
the other I can turn that into a walk I
can walk backwards or walk forward
if we were to apply that to the fountain
let's see if I faced this way if I turn
to my left shoulder my right will go
under my left arm to get to there
that'll be my clockwise fountain if I
turn to you and put my left POI under my
right that's my counterclockwise so I
can go clockwise and never done this
before I'm making accept as I go
clockwise
okay there it is cool right goes under
left goes under right goes under
I don't know that's a full fountain but
I think that lets me balance them I
could also play this way where I could
think let's see left right left under
right left right under left right left
under right left right under and build
it up that way so I find whatever it is
if there's too much time between doing
it one way and the other won't balance
them but if you find something you can
do where you're going right from the
clockwise version to the
counterclockwise version with as little
time in between and you just keep
rocking back and forth that will balance
out the move
hope you find it helpful that came from
a request
I will keep answering requests if you
keep posting them I can't promise I'll
answer them all if there's a few
requests I'll look at one that I think I
have a good answer to or that looks like
an interesting exploration yeah
interactions good for me I'm it's been
an effort to get myself going and some
of you have been really helpful with
that I really appreciate that I think we
can turn the pen to make into a POI
demek and I would like company with that
[Music]
including I need some playlists to find
some music that inspires me you know of
course I don't know if asking randomly
would lead me to that but anybody it's a
playlist they're really turned on by let
me know
and then I'll make some more stuff about
the rhythm cuz favo isn't the only guy
who knows how to dance
[Music]